ministers must stake to a set of
Standards called the ministerial code
but what exactly does it say
[Music]
it's a 39-page document that lists how
ministers are expected to behave as well
as conduct their duties with words like
professional respect and accountability
cropping up more than once the first
ministerial code was created by Tony
Blair and since then each new prime
minister usually publishes an updated
version ultimately its prime ministers
who make the final decision over whether
the code's been breached or not but some
people think that is wrong and that
somebody independent should be involved
instead
the code has 10 main points ministers
are collectively responsible for
government policies and decisions they
are responsible for the work of their
departments they must give accurate and
truthful information to Parliament and
correct any error as soon as possible
ministers who knowingly mislead
Parliament will be expected to offer
their resignation they can only withhold
information when doing so is in the
public interest civil servants who act
on a Minister's behalf or under their
direction must give accurate and
truthful information there should be no
conflict of interest between public
duties and private interests gifts or
Hospitality that could compromise a
Minister's judgment shouldn't be
accepted their ministerial role must be
kept separate from their work as an MP
government resources can't be used for
party political purposes and finally
civil servants can't be asked to act in
a way which would conflict with the
civil service code
[Music]
the code has been broken several times
before David blunkett quit as work and
pension secretary in 2005 for breaking
the ministerial code of conduct over
paid work he took without consulting an
independent committee pretty Patel was
forced to resign as International
Development secretary in 2017 over
unauthorized meetings with the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu in a
meeting that be then PM Theresa May did
not know about and with no officials
present the rules around resignations
changed during Boris Johnson's
Premiership he himself of course was
fined during the party game Scandal Mr
Johnson decided that a breach of the
ministerial code didn't necessarily mean
a minister would have to resign just
look at pretty Patel before the Home
Secretary a ministerial advisor
investigated allegations of bullying
said she had breached the code but she
didn't have to quit